hey cinephiles welcome back to another
monday morning review with a side of
spoilers today we're talking about
godzilla i'm js and i'm jimmy welcome
back godzilla yeah i mean let's just get
it out there right now
it's an awesome film go see it if you
haven't seen it i don't know what you're
doing but a lot of you did a lot yeah a
lot of people did see it 93 million it
should surprise no one
that they've announced a sequel yeah of
course um
i mean it did much better than i think a
lot of people thought yeah
and i think when you see the movie you
can
you can kind of see why yeah um the
marketing behind this beast was
phenomenal yes absolutely i really
cannot wait to see a sequel where they
they introduce
some of the older
staple characters like mothra or
or uh gigan or um
like any like all these characters
there's just so much that they could do
with the franchise now um and the way
that gareth edwards handles godzilla
is just fantastic let's talk about the
cast for a second okay um let's do that
um great cast first and foremost when it
was announced i was so excited i was
like a cast of this caliber that are
gonna be in a monster blockbuster movie
bring it on
but i mean and we're gonna get into some
spoilers here
they kill off some of the best actors
early on true and so i mean julia banosh
and brian cranston fantastic but yeah
they're gone you know an hour into the
movie now i mean this this movie is very
much about fathers and sons okay
reuniting
and and their relationship throughout
the years and what that means but and i
think that brian cranston was
phenomenal phenomenal
the first hour of godzilla i'm just
gonna say was kind of a drag because i
was waiting for this guy to show up yeah
and and i have to say once once godzilla
does show up
i mean they're spectacle but the way
that they handle
destruction and chaos and and really
like the battles in this film
is just so
artfully yeah it's just it is just so
well done gareth edwards does this thing
throughout the film where he he puts the
camera
um
in places that
more people would be actually
experiencing the instead of having like
this like
i mean there's still like these like
helicopter-esque shots or there's like
really intricate camera work that only
done doing it through cgi would allow
you to do but he puts the camera in
really um
just like it's vulnerable yeah it's very
very vulnerable like you're in the bus
with the people yeah or you're watching
on the television set in your living
room and you're like you can't do it
you're you're so hopeless right or
helpless
yeah it's really interesting the way
that the way that the camera works in
the film i really i really appreciate it
no it's fantastic and this is definitely
stemming from what edwards do with
monsters right which is as fine a
directorial debut as you can get um
about the visual style i saw this film
in 3d you did as well i did um there are
moments where we're like looking up at
the action yeah and i thought people
were standing up in my theater because i
i saw like the outline yeah figure
um between me and the monster and i was
just like what are people doing standing
up and i realized that was just part of
the 3d effect and it actually really
worked to get me there like on the
ground looking up at a kaiju
um other moments of spectacle the halo
jump which was available
on the first
um and they use the same music that 2001
music which i'm so glad they decided to
keep that in the future
that moment you won't share because
you're just in awe like i was just like
oh my gosh this is beautiful this is
incredible what i'm watching right now
um and again we assume his perspective
has he's like falling down and has he
just falls down godzilla and this muto
going at it and we just see how tiny we
are oh yeah oh yeah this is the biggest
godzilla has ever been yeah and he looks
and he looks great some people said he
looked a little chunky but yeah i think
the way that he's handled in the film
he's got
an appropriate amount of girth all right
guys so that's our review of godzilla a
strong recommendation from both of us
see it on the biggest screen possible
imax 3d in fact i would recommend it uh
you can buy your tickets right here
just fandango just click there and
you'll be covered uh for movie clips i'm
js and i'm jimmy thanks for watching
take care
you